[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS WILCOX: Hey, Martin.
I just got back from a hike.
Can we go back to Anna's problem
with authenticating her API?
MARTIN OMANDER: There's
nothing like a hike
to clear your head,
that's for sure.
CHRIS WILCOX: In a
previous episode,
we followed Anna as she
researched and settled
on using JSON web tokens to
secure Take a Hike's REST API.
In this episode, we'll
see the code she wrote.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER:
Anna is a developer
working for Take a Hike, a
fitness tracking startup.
She built a REST API to enable
their users to record hikes
from mobile and web apps.
She secured the API
with JSON web tokens.
CHRIS WILCOX: In a
previous episode,
we showed the code
for the REST API.
It runs on Cloud Run, so
it's serverless and doesn't
require any server maintenance.
Check out that
episode if you want
to see how to write a REST API.
MARTIN OMANDER: Here's what
Anna's prototype looks like.
From this web page,
users should be
able to sign-in using their
identity provider of choice.
Once they have signed
in, they should
see their recorded hikes.
Users should only be able
to see their own hikes.
CHRIS WILCOX: Anna reads up on
Firebase Auth, which supports
multiple identity providers.
It also includes a default user
interface called Firebase UI.
MARTIN OMANDER: The code
for Anna's prototype
is linked in the
description below.
Let's look at the
most important pieces.
CHRIS WILCOX: In
her JavaScript code,
Anna initializes
Firebase UI, which
will display one button for
each identity provider shown
to the user.
She also tells the
Firebase UI library
which page to redirect
to after the user has
signed in successfully.
Finally, she renders the
Firebase UI component.
MARTIN OMANDER:
On the next page,
the one that users are
redirected to when they log
in successfully, Anna
calls the getIdToken().
The string she gets back is a
signed JSON web token, which
contains the user's unique ID.
CHRIS WILCOX: After
fetching the ID token,
Anna's code requests
the user's hikes
by calling the
server-side REST API.
Her code includes the ID token
and the authorization header
of the call.
MARTIN OMANDER: As
we saw last time,
Anna implemented the
server-side REST API in Node.js
running on Cloud Run.
Her server-side code
reads the JSON web token
from the authorization header
and extracts the user's ID
from it.
Her server-side code
then uses this ID
to ask the database for that
particular user's hikes.
CHRIS WILCOX: But wait.
How does Anna verify that
the JSON web token is valid?
And how does she extract
the user ID from it?
As mentioned in
our previous video,
Anna has limited experience
with cryptography.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's where
the Firebase SDK comes in.
If Anna imports this package
into her server-side code,
it has a method called
verifyIdToken() that does just
that.
It verifies the token and
extracts the user ID from it
if it is valid.
If the token is invalid--
for example, if a malicious user
is attacking Anna's REST API--
the verifyIdToken()
call will not succeed,
and Anna's code can
return an error.
CHRIS WILCOX: That's neat.
Anna has now
secured her REST API
so users can only
access their own hikes,
and she did it without
having to become
an expert in cryptography.
The libraries did most
of the heavy lifting.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That's right, Chris.
It's always important to use
tested and reliable packages
when working with cryptography.
CHRIS WILCOX: So
now that Take a Hike
has fixed their nike
recording system,
I think I'll start planning
my next expedition.
MARTIN OMANDER: Where do
you think you'll go, Chris?
CHRIS WILCOX: I'm not sure.
But I think it'll be further
away than my refrigerator.
[MUSIC PLAYING]